[Musique]
ce sera aux parts égales sera le dernier
jingle de cette émission merci le sauve
ton pote c'est très simple regardez il y
à benjamin castaldi qui accroché à des
cordes
je vais vous poser des questions médias
si vous répondez bien si vous répondez
bien tout se passe bien vous sauvez
votre pote ps si vous répondez mal où on
coupera chaque fois une corde d'accord
c'est bon c'est amaury qui est derrière
toi merci
amaury mon ami merci voilà merci ça va
bien en tout cas cette petite
combinaison ou va à merveille bravo à
l'ailé chéri question bd valérie bénaïm
oui vrai ou faux et vous jouez avec nous
chez vous la copine de killian mba p
c'est le buzz en petite tenue sur un
star
je veux dire vrai vrai eh bien eh bien
eh bien eh bien eh bien c'est faux non
c'est la petite amie de qui de notre
football cristiano ronaldo et la chérie
de cristiano ronaldo
georgina n'en finit plus de casser la
toile avec ses poses et clichés
volontairement sexy regardez franchement
elle avait déjà commencé il ya dix jours
voilà regarder avec une séance de
fitness
ah oui alors attendez deux minutes parce
que moi je connais cette plage je
connais cette plage me dit quelque chose
ah oui abattant étend son linge comme
pas tout cas je ne sais pas c'est le
brésil
la nouvelle beauce la france voit ses
bases est méchamment
alors mes jolies alors ensuite regarder
elle a remis ça allait de retour dans sa
salle préférée la salle de sport ah oui
ah bah oui en effet en effet alors ça
c'est ça c'est quoi ce alors ça c'est
pour travailler tous qui abdou expirant
d'accord
merci voilà et donc c'est vrai qu'elle a
affolé tout le monde est franchement on
dira ce qu'on voudra
c'est un avion de chasse elle est
exceptionnelle
moi j'ai pas mon délire c'est à vomir
non ça n'est pas mon délire mon délire
il est la haye hélas hélas en diagonale
c'est diabolus demandé c'est vrai est
franchement très bon d'ailleurs pas
votre délire doivent pas des chaussettes
par dessus de leggings lmp l'ipad allait
donc on va on va couper une corde avant
l'heure à castanet dit attention c'est
parti on va couper d'un couple avait la
première voilà la veille sur l'axé la
bonne
castaldi pour l'instant c'est bon
attention besoin jean michel meyer
question la police retrouve à plus 1
la police a retrouvé un fugitif
après l'avoir entendu péter vrai ou faux
faux non c'est vrai et c'est vrai on
pourrait croire que c'est une vanne mais
pas du tout regardez cette histoire
c'est la police de notthingham la police
de nottingham exactement ce soir
regardez cette histoire à peine croyable
se déroule à art works près de doncaster
dans le centre de l'angleterre
l'histoire d'une cabale qui a mal tourné
pour un fugitif retrouvé et identifié
par la police à cause d'un petit
problème digestif
alors que cet homme était recherché par
la police pour avoir à deux reprises
éviter une convocation au tribunal
la police est allée ce n'est chez
l'intéressé sans réponse de sa part les
agents tout de suite décidé de faire le
tour de la maison et d'observer s'il y
avait de l'activité dans le jardin ou
par les fenêtres c'est à ce moment
précis qu'un policier découvre loin
quelqu'un qui prend la fuite
très vite ils comprennent qu'il s'agit
de leurs hommes et il se lance alors
dans une course poursuite sauf qu'avec
l'avancé qu'il a prise le fugitif gagne
du terrain et sème les agents de police
qui désormais ne le voit plus alors que
l'homme semble loin les policiers
continuent de le chercher à l'endroit où
il a été vu pour la dernière fois et
c'est un bruit fracassant qui va
permettre aux agents de trouver le
fugitif
un bruit de paix en effet l'homme très
stressée par cette course poursuite n'a
pas pu s'empêcher de lâcher un gas pour
le moins sonore caché derrière un
buisson les policiers se dirigent vers
l'endroit d'où provient le son et tombe
nez à nez avec leurs hommes
comme quoi la prochaine fois que vous
entamez une cavale penser à manger léger
c'est exceptionnel et ça franchement
c'est dingue weekly la peur déclenché la
diarrhée non sport exactement pour ça
qu'il a dû bas se lâcher parce que il a
dû vraiment vraiment flippé bien sûr et
ça lui a créé balle et bien c'est pour
ça qu'on dit voilà on dit je vais me
faire dessus quand on a tout simplement
voilà voilà bah castaldi doit voir très
souvent peur eux
vous n'avez pas peur là benjamin non pas
du tout allez on coupa deuxième film
puisque jean michel mr a perdu voilà à
et non c'est toujours pas le bon allez
question pour vous kelly un jeune homme
a trouvé 135 mille dollars et les ajouté
en pensant que c'était des billets de
jeux de société vrai ou faux
c'est faux et oui c'est faux non c'est
faux il les a rendus non non non c'était
des vrais billets et les a rendus ne
pensais pas que c'était des piliers de
jeux de société
regardez l'histoire et oui il faut bien
écouter le leur a laissé un jeune homme
trouve 135 mille dollars et les jette en
pensant que ce sont des billets de jeux
de société non ils les arts ont dû
regarder cette histoire complètement ouf
qui est arrivé aux etats-unis
c'est un très très beau geste d'un jeune
homme de 19 ans je sais pas si tout le
monde aurait fait ça regardez ce qu'il a
fait
[Musique]
il est au paradis et aux parades et je
vais vous dire et la police lui a donné
500 dollars c'est toujours le way pour
le récompenser par rapport à je leur ai
dit la vérité qui aurait rendu l'oseille
moi j'aurais eu la trouille en fait
bahreïn 35000 dollars vous imaginez que
ça c'est pas forcément de l'argent
propre alors vous vous dites si ça se
trouve ça appartient à un gang ou
incroyable ou de la chasse à l'homme
après mois à venir me chercher on va
essayer de récupérer l'argent personne
venir par patoche personne et vous
cherchez oui on va plutôt crever que de
le rendre à votre garde isabelle mois
par nature et par prudence comme valérie
je leur ai rendu mais bon ils vont à oui
mais vous êtes vraiment quelle source
touareg - vous connaissez
bah quoi garde regarder mais vous même
mais par superstition j'aurais fait je
me serais dit pourquoi ça tombe sur moi
c'est un message j'aurais donné un
associé part je vous jure genre à donner
à ce que j'ai dit ok mais c'est à dire
que je regardais quand même les pires
des pires que vraiment ouais enfin 5000
euros la clique et je les rentrées des
studios fédérant tout de suite à 135
vous êtes tout seuls n'y a pas de témoin
n'y a pas de caméra vous levez la tête
n'y a pas de caméra et loire et à gaza
sont fermées il n'y a pas de station
service et vous voyez là rien qui peut
du matériel et surtout vous voyez moi
qui au dire la vérité ça ici on peut pas
les passions je vais vous dire pourquoi
je ne prends pas qu'on serait que c'est
un piège d'arthur ouais c'est que si si
vous vous ramener l'argent bout de un an
et un jour ces personnes avait clamé il
est à vous d'accord si tu veux faire une
bonne action
bah oui d'accord merci était super bien
à l'ailé chéri question pour isabelle
morini-bosc jean pierre pernaut s'est
lancé sur tik tok
il cartonne vrai ou faux
c'est faux oui ce sont ses enfants qui
cartonne et ils mettent en scène leur
père regardez on a je vous dis les
petits-enfants de tome 16 ans et lou 18
ans qui sont les enfants de jean pierre
pernaut et ce sont des stars de tik tok
nous à 2,2 millions de j'aime sur son
tik tok et post très régulièrement des
vidéos et non elle n'hésite pas à parler
de son père et même à le mettre en scène
regardez cette petite compil des enfants
de jean pierre pernaut est normalement
quand on parle de jean pierre pernaut ya
la tanière c'est la règle
[Musique]
véronique fait un infarctus a dit quoi
je ne te reconnais pas photo c'est pas
choquant syst du coup j'ai dit je te
dirais qui tu te fais pas la gueule j'ai
pas d'idée témoin je ne te reconnais pas
[Musique]
bon
dans son très joli franchement oui oui
et oui je vais faire un petit mea culpa
ce qui hier je t'aimerai jeu mais
c'était plutôt enclin à penser que tf1
n'avait un peu sanctionnés pour les
propos qu'il avait tenus un peu contre
gouvernement et serra j'ai enquêté toute
la journée aujourd'hui pour essayer de
trouver quelqu'un qui me donnent raison
malheureusement toutes les personnes que
j'ai appelé que des très belles informé
m'ont dit que non c'était vraiment pour
un néo pro c'est une question de santé
qu'il était toujours confiné chez lui
qui reviendra dès la semaine prochaine
donc je fais mes excuses et je vois le
genre je reconnais que mon erreur donc
voilà il ya raymond qui suit c'est ce
que le dernier qui a critiqué le
gouvernement c'est ppda il a à dire au
revoir en breton bien sûr j'ai l'avant
dernier qui a critiqué le gouvernement
giuly vous savez qu'ils étaient ceux qui
on est la taupe ou là les chéris
question pour vous question pour vous
merci pour vous pour vous asseoir et
qu'on soit selon une étude recoucher
avec son ex permet d'aller de l'avant
vrai ou faux c'est faux c'est faux et
bien c'est vrai nom c'est une info qui
va rassurer pas mal de monde
si j'avais pendant le confinement
certains ont craqué et se sont de
nouveau rapproché de leur ex comme vous
valérie bénaïm ne vous inquiétez pas une
étude vient de montrer qu avoir des
relations sexuelles avec son ex
n'empêchait pas de guérir de la rupture
vous je sais que malheureusement il
n'est plus de ce monde mais vous tout
est très bien cette taxe est malgré tout
tourner la page
à regarder c'est une étude scientifique
très sérieuse qui m'intéressait tout le
monde
un kansas intéresse intéresse le public
à makanza ce confinement vous vous êtes
senti très seul et vous avez renouer le
contact avec votre ex dans l'optique de
vous faire une petite soirée olé olé
revival de vos nuits les plus torrides
avec le déconfinement vous devez
sûrement vous dire que vous avez fauté
carroll s'est recouché avec son ex c'est
toujours une mauvaise idée du moins
c'est ce qu'on pensait car aujourd'hui
une étude provenant des états unis nous
déculpabiliser à ce sujet fini de
pleurer en découvrant que bourré vous
avez envoyé un sms à votre ex à 4h du
mat selon cette enquête menée par la
très sérieuse wayne state university
dans le michigan recoucher avec son ex
ne serait pas mauvais pour passer à
autre chose le sexe post-rupture
n'entraverait pas la guérison
psychologique
en clair vous ne risquez pas de souffrir
plus en replongeant ce serait même le
contraire
l'étude précise toutefois que pour se
dire adieu ou faire le deuil d'une
relation retourner dans les bras de son
ex doit être une exception une fois ou
deux fois tout au plus
sinon vous risquez de vous attacher et
de ne pas réussir à vous plonger dans
une nouvelle relation finalement c'est
la chanteuse jane manson qui avait
raison depuis le début
[Musique]
avant de nous dire avant de nous dire
adieu alors couché avec son écran est
lui un peu permettre de dali de la
banque kelly question pensent à moi je
trouve que c'est de la grosse grosse
grosse bêtise alors peut-être une étude
scientifique
ça vient d'amérique tout est étudié
d'amérique s'est fait rare qu'on dit une
étude du guatemala aux états unis qu'ils
étudient que ses propres aux américains
mais moi je pense sincèrement que c'est
une grosse bêtise de dravet cas et
surtout si la nana ou le mec est
complètement en dépression depuis être
avec son amoureux vraiment que le mix
lamoureux ouais en fait marc ça ça
s'appelle un plan cul et je vois pas
l'intérêt bah oui bah si bas alors voilà
basile fois bas regarder elle regardait
avec son ex jean-roger non mais sans
rigoler mais là il dit dans l'étude que
ça sert mais je vois pas non mais ça
sert à aller de l'avant à passer à autre
chose ces bâtons mais non parce que
c'est elle je connais il ya plein de
filles qui veulent pas aller avec un
autre mec et d'autre mais qui va pas il
d'autres modes fils connaisse tout ça il
dit c'est la phase aller regarder vers
les personnes que ce dernière 2
l'acca une blessure de ce2 ce2 de
refouiller l'appelait ça me fasse à 4 55
jours jean-michel question pensent ces
spécialistes de l'amour moi je cède
parfois c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
j'ai beaucoup de demandes après une
lettre au hasard comme ça j'en ouvre une
et puis je suis après j'y vais mais je
le fais rarement parce qu'après le
problème c'est que les gens seraient
accroche ça fait deuxième rupture parce
qu'ils disent qu'il ya pas de sentiment
c'est juste comme ça parce qu'on se
connaît mais non il ya toujours un qui
soit lié à l'alchimie du real man c'est
exactement toujours acquis sur euler dvd
il m'a beaucoup souffert un jeu mais pas
bon son avec ça c'est le doigt dans la
porte
castaldi aller pour l'instant alors
attention
c'était la dernière question ouais est
ce que c'est le fils qui va envoyer
benjamin peu par hasard alors vous allez
kiffer le orange à les y attend attendez
j'ai coupé plutôt le noir je pense
formule n'a pas pourquoi oui c'est vrai
tu veux tu as
[Rires]
savent à quel saint mamet du nord à
novara que tu sois belge et il va les
changer benji magnifique mais qu'elle
tarde cassano les médias laissent et d'y
aller ou plutôt les noirs tient le plus
le mot oui oui oui
ces packs j'en faisais venu quand j'ai
senti plus anti sida